willow
pour
shirov et donc voilà nous allons
procéder maintenant la 12e à la deuxième
demi finale de ce grand prix l'échec du
sénat je vous rappelle que demain la
petite finale aura lieu à partir de
10h30 et que la finale la grande finale
aura lieu elle à partir de 14h30
suivra après 17 heures une simultanée
dans les jardins du luxembourg alors là
simultanée jardin du luxembourg j'ai eu
avec mon père 30 joueurs qui s'en occupe
alors bertrand ce que tu peut éclairer
nos amis sur cette simultanées il y aura
les quatre champions joueront sur à peu
près 60 échiquier donc après le tournoi
à partir de 17h ça se passera dans les
jardins du luxembourg à l'endroit où
certainement beaucoup connaissent ici on
joue aux échecs habituellement et si
vous voulez si certaines personnes dans
la salle veulent s'inscrire
ma qui viennent me voir à la pause entre
les deux parties tout à l'heure où ou à
la fin du match tout simplement
voilà où demain donc je répète demain il
ya une simultanée pour clos pour clore
le tournoi les non pas ici dans les
jardins du luxembourg
il y aura 60 échiquier et les quatre
champions joueront donc contre 60
personnes non à partir de 17 heures
après la finale tout simplement
voilà donc vous pouvez venir vous
inscrire auprès de moi quand vous le
souhaitez
merci voilà donc pour procéder
maintenant cette deuxième demi finale
nous allons accueillir deux très grands
champions
c'était même les on peut dire les deux
favoris du tournoi au classement elo
puisque c'est eux qui avaient les deux
les deux classements et le lait plus
élevé je vais d'ailleurs d'abord
accueillir un joueur qui en france b
compte beaucoup parce que c'est le
numéro un français
c'est aussi le joueur qui dans le monde
alain secours positif contre garry
kasparov y en a pas beaucoup
il c'est un des seuls puisqu'ils boris
boycot aussi un score positif contre
garde contre garry kasparov
il mène deux victoires à une je crois et
7,7 parties nulles
il s'agit du grand maître international
joël lautier
ls
alors pour affronter pour affronter joël
lautier donc notre numéro un national
on a un joueur du top niveau mondial il
est numéro quatre mondial depuis
maintenant plusieurs années il avait été
désigné comme tous nos challengers pour
un match contre garry kasparov qui n'a
pas et qu'il n'a pas eu lieu
il a gagné le grand prix de bordeaux il
ya deux ans tournoi qui donc était à
l'origine de ce grand prix du sénat
c'est le numéro quatre mondial actuel il
est espagnol d'origine lettone alexei
shirov de la nabe lire bien fort
donc pour cette deuxième demi finale
encore une fois je donne la parole à
sacha la musique général a ajouté juste
bon match bienvenue donc pour cette
deuxième demi finale donc deuxième demi
finale du premier grand prix du sénat
qui vient de démarrer donc alexis shirov
à jouer le pion du roi 1e cat
ce n'est pas une surprise un c'est l'un
de ces coups favori jean-luc tout à fait
donc joël qui répondent par une défense
espagnole donc actuellement et qui joue
un système rare mais qu'il connaît très
très bien donc avec des 6 7 5
une position qu'il a joué contre de très
très fort joueur d'ailleurs je crois que
tu as des statistiques intéressantes à
nous dévoiler
oui sur sur cette variante pas encore
mettre en place les joueurs se
développent rapidement je n'étais pas
connecté et donc après fou des trois
tours donc joël qui décident
immédiatement donc de d'empêcher les
blancs de pousser leurs pions des donc
retarder le développement et et après
lui de jouer cavalier f6 et petit road
probablement une variante assez risqué
de la part de joël quand même parce
qu'on va tout de suite qu'il affaiblit
le côté noir s'il va jouer petit rock
petit rang qui peut surgir des dames b3
échec
donc faut vraiment être très prudents ou
alors jouer dan 17 et temporiser un peu
oui alors c'est une variante jean-luc
que nous avions travaillé avec joël en
94 dont il a joué son match contre
vienne timan dans le cadre
du championnat du monde des quarts de
finale du tournoi des candidats et il
est très très affûté sur cette variante
et je pense qu'il a quelques idées
nouvelles d'ailleurs donc joël lautier
devrait nous gratifier d'une partie
spectaculaire
je me rappelle notamment de variantes
avec des sacrifices de pièces où il
obtenait une très très forte attaque
avec les noirs et si ma mémoire est
bonne il a déjà battu shirov avec cette
variante avec les noirs et oui donc joël
qui a changé puisque aller au grand prix
de bordeaux il avait joué une sicilienne
donc contre contre michael adams ça ne
lui avait pas réussi mais il avait dû
gagner donc dans cette position alors
que là nous avons le plaisir donc de de
parler donc au grand maître arnaud
hauchard qui va peut-être nous donner
ses impressions donc très très fair play
il est venu dans la salle de
commentaires pour donner un petit peu
ses impressions sur son match contre
boris un match fantastique
oui qu'est ce que je peux dire
j'aime beaucoup boris et puis au début
j'étais déjà été assez décontracté au
fur et à mesure la pression est montée
juillet plus grand-chose tactiquement
alors qu'au début mon ambition c'était
bien de bien calculer par la suite se
jouait plus grand chose je jouais avec
mes mains comme le disent pas ce qui est
au bout d'un moment on joue plus avec sa
tête on joue avec ses mains tu n'as pas
été impressionné par la vitesse
d'exécution dans certains types de
position comme quand il a joué sept
premières sicilienne si j'étais j'ai vu
qu'il était capable de jouer très vite
et dès fois de bloquer mais c'est cédric
position très typique j'ai je commence à
cécilienne je joue là car au canada ce
candidat avait donc j'ai pas l'habitude
comme lui de position j'ai été assez
impressionné
en tout cas on a beaucoup admiré ton cou
cavaliers 3 qui était vraiment un coup
très très très très intelligent dans la
deuxième partie pour créer des
affaiblissements et cette partie
stratégiquement était vraiment une
partie et de jouer par un fort joueur et
j'ai peut-être
j'ai peut-être été un petit peu à la fin
en proposant nul parce que la position
quand même très difficile pour les noirs
mais j'avais trois minutes et c'était
peut-être un aveu de faiblesse de ce que
j'aurais pu faire cette partie je pense
ainsi que la combinaison lorsque j'ai
perdu mon pions et de je pense que je
vais gagner dans cette position j'ai
complètement oublié le pire u2 et je
pense que ça se serait terminée comme ça
si j'avais roulé le cahier d'ici je
pense que j'ai plusieurs cures peut-être
simplement cavaliers g5 je sais pas moi
je pense que tu as raté d'un problème
5,1 en données ou les données puis 1-2
tuera d'un broyeur 5
après quand il reprend tu fait cavalier
m6 échec fourchette rouge fruité
cavaliers prend 1,8 tu récupère le
matériel avec une position plus un pion
plus nette ce jeu là c'est là que j'ai
perdu le match mages
voilà donc la partie entre joël qui a
les noirs et alexei shirov continue donc
donc arnaud qui vient de nous faire un
commentaire très très très très
sympathique de sa partie est donc un
match très tendu contre un champion du
monde c'est quand même un exploit c'est
quand même vraiment quelque chose de
très très bien ici on peut voir que
shirov réfléchit alors il y à un seul
coup apparemment ces cavaliers h3 mais
peut-être dans son style il réfléchit à
puis on prend 1,4 suffit de comprendre
les cinq est d'alger six échecs on sait
pas où calcul qui a valu six dames 17 8
cavaliers 4 pour acheter ça quand même
affaiblie quand même la caisse g6 et qui
a valu un cavalière 3 wii peuvent eux
donc le lait le joël doc qui continue à
se développer cavaliers des deux donc
chaque joueur se développe pour cette
position alexei voudrait probablement
échangé ce pion e4 qui le gêne un petit
peu et finalement affaiblir un petit peu
la grande diagonale b 1 h cette voie là
c'est ce qui se passe donc il a et
n'amène ces pièces vers vers les droits
et il va finalement activé son jeu de
pièces donc jean-claude oui pour le
moment les deux joueurs sont en train de
suivre une partie récente qui s'est joué
donc
au mémorial chigot rinne en 1999 entre
un joueur russe
djouba ayant des mires off est un qui
est un maître à 2481 donc un bon joueur
et tour et cède 7 coups qui a été joué
dans cette partie les blancs avaient
joué cavalier en f4 donc pour le moment
tout cela est connu de la théorie est
sans doute connu des deux joueurs et
c'est le moment où peut-être l'un des
deux va placer une amélioration pour son
camp peut-être qu'ils vont continuer
très très loin puisque tu m'a montré une
partie qu'ils ont joué ensemble où ils
ont poursuivi la théorie pendant trente
deux coups et c'est une menace et une
partie qu'ils ont jouée en partie
classique dans le championnat
d'allemagne par équipe en bundesliga
joël lautier avec les blancs c'était une
green feld et ils ont en fait répéter
une partie cram nick shirov jusqu'aux
trente deuxième coup pour le même
résultat ils ont fait nul d'ailleurs
dans la partie donc là pour le moment
tout cela est connu
je pense que avec les blancs alexis
shirov essaye soin de se remémorer ce
qui a été joué dans cette position soit
de trouver un coup nouveau soin de
vérifier une idée nouvelle
carrément ou que mon cher jean claude
nous avons une armada de préparateur de
deux secondes ans qui vont nous aider à
commenter cette partie puisque nous
avons donc robert fontaine champion de
france junior et aussi arnaud hauchard
qui est dans l'autre cabinet qui sera
prêt à intervenir à n'importe quel
moment
donc je pense que la partie va être bien
bien analysé voilà les supporters
d'arnaud chars vont pouvoir donc cédé se
délecter de ces de ces analyses
et puis bon il le verrons demain aussi
pour le match de classement
arnaud donc va rester avec nous à être
un peu notre consultant de luxe
oui oui donc arnaud
donc oui oui je découvre un peu les
systèmes mais je n'interviendrai quand
ce sera nécessaire peut-être sur
quelques variantes pour l'instant je
pense que
joël s'est bien préparés parce que j'ai
vu ce genre de partie pour l'instant ça
ça a l'air d'être ok pour jour elle donc
pour l'instant je peux intervenir si les
ventes techniques éventuellement
peut-être donc dans cette position
connaît actuellement le coût cavaliers
h3 f4 qui revient vers le centre hélas
les noirs recyclent leurs fous 7 et le
mettre en d6 c'est une diagonale ou le
fou est plus utile puisqu'il vise le
pion h2i la grande diagonale b 8 h 2
donc une diagonale ou le fou peut
exercer sa sa force de fou c'est donc
sur toutes ces cases noires donc une
structure de pions qui est très
symétriques puisque actuellement les
blancs ont des pions abcd contre des
pions noirs a b c d et des pions g h
contre des pions noirs g h il mais avec
un petit avantage pour les blancs
puisque la chaîne de pions blanche est
comment dire est très très saine
le pion b2 descend le pion c3 qui défend
le pion des quatre on appelle ça une
chaîne de pions les noirs donc sont un
peu moins bien au niveau la structure
mais mais les noirs sont bien développés
oui ce qu'on peut dire aussi dans cette
position c'est
bon la partie c'est qu'on connaisse et
continuer par cavalier par cavalli f4
food et 6 et les blancs ont marqué le
point alors que fit site îlots important
donc c'est peut-être pas de très bon
augure pour les supporters de de joël
mais à mon avis si joël lautier que je
connais bien
d'où cette position c'est qu'il a une
idée c'est pas quelqu'un qui récite et
qui suis comme ça sans vérifier bien sûr
les parties des autres
donc c'est qu'il a une idée et sans
doute une amélioration c'est la raison
sans doute pour laquelle à l'itie shirov
qui doit être méfiant parce quand même
beaucoup de temps car il est certain
qu'il connaît le coût qui a été joué
dans cette position et oui ils passent
beaucoup de temps que d'ailleurs il a
saisi lui reste 5 minutes 24 alors que
joël lui a n'a dépensé que 40 secondes
donc c'est incroyable je veux dire ça
fait dix minutes d'écart c'est quand
même c'est quand même quelque chose de
pas ordinaire à ce niveau oui ben la
raison c'est shirov doit se méfier il
doit se dire il y a quelque chose donc
ils essayent de trouver l'idée qu'aurait
pu trouver le numéro un français lens
est dans cette position qui est quand
même très très bien préparés de toute
façon pour jouer à ce niveau il faut il
faut être bien préparé
surtout quand on affronte régulièrement
des joueurs de la trempe de shirov pas
encore mettre le feu puisque déjà il
sacrifie il ne sacrifie pas de pièces
mais il a déjà sacrifié dix minutes donc
jouer avec 10 minutes de handicap face à
un joueur aussi fort que joël lautier
n'est pas une chose évidente donc
cavalier f2 c'est une nouveauté parce
que dans la partie devant matti cité
jeunes cavaliers f4 alors qu'elle élève
de l'idée est d'empêcher le cavalier
noir devenir 4 qui est un très bon poste
alors peut-être qu'il va s'en fout des
six
oui peut-être le fou va se recycler en
des 6es et le cavalier f2 pourrait venir
sur le fou aux fous des deux tout
simplement cavaliers cavaliers hausse en
est peut-être fait des six peut-être
cavaliers 215 salle et un cavalier au
centre tout en contrôlant les cases du
cavalier f6 aussi ouais on a vu ce pas
ce qui dans les tenants saumâtre contre
arnaud justement développer
tranquillement ses pièces par food et 2
comme on a vu dans les 6 yens peut-être
shirov a effectué la même chose avec
food et 2 et d'oubli ses tours sur la
colonne veut tout simplement avait comme
tu dis plus tard posté le cavalier en ce
sens que lui il est possible que que
alex ayez compris que lecavalier en f4
n'était peut-être pas sur sa meilleure
case et qu'il fallait plus qu'il était
plus prudent de contrôler certaines
cases comme la casse g4 et la case e cat
et donc de faire ça d'abord et après de
développer ces pièces et c'est un choix
curieux c'est un petit de positions
douteuses dans lesquelles il n'est pas
vraiment spécialiste ce n'est pas
vraiment son type de position puisque
c'est quand même un joueur qui aime les
positions complètement éclaté avec des
structures contre métriques asymétriques
voire même 10 troy
donc ils recherchent donc des positions
un petit peu plus un peu plus un peu
plus éclectique et donc dans cette
position il a il est obligé de jouer une
certaine forme de deux classiques de
jeux classiques c'est quand même pas
évident pour lui une petite chose par
rapport à l'attitude de joël qui a
blessé les premiers coups donc il
montrant clairement à son adversaire
qu'il connaissait cette position et
maintenant il se met à réfléchir sur
le cavalier f2 qui est inquiet d'un coup
nouveau sas et c'est quand même moi ce
niveau là ils peuvent peut-être se
permettre mais de montrer le moment on
ne connaît plus n'est peut-être pas
forcément une bonne chose
et même quand on connaît les coûts
d'ouverture c'est bien quand même de
réfléchir ça permet de rentrer dans la
partie et également de donner aucune
indication à son adversaire
quant à son niveau de connaissance d'une
ouverture c'est un choix mais certains
joueurs font ce que tu dis c'est à dire
ils réfléchissent même s'ils connaissent
la position mais d'autres joueurs comme
garry kasparov joue tant qu'ils
connaissent et aiment dire jusqu'au 40e
c'est à dire jusqu'au 40e coup dans le
casse par orf réfléchit plus tôt mais il
joue tant qu'il connaît et que tant
qu'il est sûr de la position de son
travail il joue et je pense que joël à
une approche aussi très rigoureuse et
très scientifique qui qui fait qu'
actuellement ils réfléchi parce que
c'est une nouveauté est donc il doit
réfléchir
son travail est fini de toute manière et
dans la partie à une phase de transition
c'est à dire qu'au sortir de l'ouverture
chaque camp doit se fixer un plan et à
mon avis c'est dans cette position qu'il
faut fixer le plan placer les pièces au
bon endroit et c'est pour ça que les
joueurs prennent autant de temps pour
réfléchir
oui en plus bon le coup cavalli f2 va
mener la même idée que cavalière cad
c'est le cavalier veut sans doute
transiter par la case d3 pour aller en
cinq dons qu'ils soient en f2 ou f3 ça
se trouve ça n'aura aucune aucune
signification par rapport à kasparov
on lui peut effectivement se permettre
de jouer les coups très rapidement ce ça
donne aucune indication à c'est à dire
ça parce que de toute façon tout le
monde sait qui connaît beaucoup de
choses
une fois maurice goal com a dit il
connaît tous et plus que tout donc pour
pour
donner une information à ce sujet ici
sans doute le coup des noirs doit être
fou des six comme dans la partie qu'on a
mentionné car il faut absolument
recycler ce fou qui n'a pas une qui
n'est pas très actif pour le moment avec
peut-être l'idée de jouer ensuite la
tour en 1 7 pourquoi pas donc on peut
demander à alors on verra qui est l'un
de nos invités
ici on fout des six oui bah écoutes je
pense que c'est une ouverture que joël
connaît particulièrement bien donc jean
luc donc ce que je pense de cette
position donc oui oui donc fou des deux
dans cette position les blancs se
développe
ils contrôlent fou des six coups des
deux donc les blancs vont se développer
les blancs vont jouer sur un petit
avantage donc un petit davantage de
structures de développement
il faut savoir quand même que la
position symétrique rend la tâche
difficile donc mais c'est quand même
intéressant de voir un chiffre très très
timide très timide pour cette rencontre
donc juste un petit mot aux spectateurs
donc faites attention à ne pas mettre
donc les écouteurs trop trop fort parce
que les joueurs peuvent entendre voilà
donc un petit mot technique
la position est relativement équilibré
en fait seul et les noirs auront
peut-être une solution pour eux pour
égaliser
c'est d'essayer de liquider les pièces
lourdes sur la colonne eux donc
peut-être le coutour e7 dans cette
position peut être un coup peut être un
coup intéressant avec l'idée de prendre
et pourquoi pas ensuite joué dame f8
suivi de tours à huit dans le dans le
même esprit dame 17 pour être joué mais
l'inconvénient serait l'arrivée bien sûr
d'un cavalier a eu 5 qui attaqueraient
la dame au bon moment donc ça serait
peut-être une une perte de temps pour
les pour les noirs aux 7 il faut
peut-être faire attention à certaines
certains coups de dames blanches
peut-être qu'ils peuvent surgir non
faire et comme d'alger 6 ou même
cavalier h4 pour prendre la place g6
avec lecavalier et sur dan 17 je pense
pas que ce soit une bonne idée parce
qu'il ya cavaliers 5 directement et on
s'aperçoit que il faut prendre avec le
fou car sur cavaliers prend il y avait
dès demain puis on prend avec une
fourchette et sur la prise donc avec le
fou puis on prend et le pion aux 5
devient très fort avec la poussée en
aussi ce qui peut être très désagréable
pour les noirs et sinon que penser d'un
coup comme un coup assez fond de court
comme dame f8 par exemple ça peut être
aussi une bonne idée pour mettre la tour
en 1 8es échangé cette pièce qui
actuellement ne joue pas mais encore la
même idée cavaliers h4 peut être gênant
pour donc menacer la dame en fuite qui
serait
qui serait menacée c'est vrai mais
peut-être après dames et fuite cavalli h
4 on peut peut-être
quelquefois on peut faire intervenir le
plonger en jouant g5 ça serait très
risqué très risqué quand je pense ou et
parce que le roi blanc le roi noir
serait à découvert vraiment il peut y
avoir des cavaliers f5 ou dame g6 on
n'est pas comme dans la partie arnaud ou
bourse parce qu'ils avaient joué j'ai
cinq ici le renoir vraiment très
affaibli et si on le prépare par
cavalier hausse est sûre cavaliers h4
voilà peut-être ensuite j'ai cinq sceaux
deviendra intéressant
voilà donc peut-être mais bon on ne
conseille pas donc au second
téléspectateurs de jouer et donc de
pousser se plonger dans ce type de
position seulement lorsque le le passage
à l'offensive est nécessaire donc l'âge
où elle réfléchit dans cette position il
réfléchit c'est une position en réalité
très tactique puisque il n'y a pas de
décisions stratégiques importantes à
prendre au centre puisque le le
structurer figé donc il faut trouver le
placement de pièces très très précis la
parole est aux pièces dans ce type de
position il faut trouver le placement
très harmonieux pour que les pièces
puissent passer à l'offensive
voilà il joue dames et fuite alors un
très bon coup dames et fuite en fait il
veut il veut jouer tout simplement tour
à 8 pour essayer d'échanger déjà une
paire de tours sur la colonne jean-luc
les statistiques de dechy rohff avec les
blancs sont quand même avec les pièces
blanches sont très impressionnantes
puisque il a 67 % de résultats positifs
avec les pièces blanches donc c'est pour
mieux mesurer la tâche qui attend joël
lautier dans cette partie et que dire de
son pourcentage aussi face à la
sicilienne où il est terrible c'est un
joueur qui ne se posent pas de questions
ils jouent vous sur l'a6 sienne il ouvre
le centre il sort ses pièces allèles
dames et il fait grand qui y poussent
tout quoi le lien c'est très clair et
c'est souvent comme ça c'est vraiment un
joueur incroyable je me souviens
d'ailleurs d'une partie contre judit
polgar qui est la meilleure joueuse du
monde de la planète dans laquelle il
avait il avait joué avec leur au centre
une partie incroyable une défense nash
d'or fais ce que tu t'en souviens mon
cher jean claude est tout à fait une
partie vous l'avez tous sacrifiés il y
avait eu des cavaliers des 5
et des cavaliers cabello 6 d'abord à
cavaliers des cinq avec des sacrifices
dans tous les sens mais dans l'esprit
d'aider des amateurs et même des grands
maîtres
alix ichiro fait un petit peu le
successeur de michael talent qui
enflammait bien sûr les c'est parti par
des sacrifices brillant mais à la
différence de talent c'est que shirov à
une préparation quand même bien
supérieure dans les dents les ouvertures
exactement c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à nos téléspectateurs de canal
web pendant l'entracte je leur ai
expliqué que que ces deux joueurs qui
sont originaires de riga donc en
lettonie donc shirov actuellement à la
nationalité donc espagnole depuis
quelques années mais ces deux joueurs
donc shirov étals sont des joueurs
fantastiques extrêmement doué dans les
positions compliquées
ils ont le génie un talent inné pour
trouver des sacrifices des choses
incroyables
la seule différence c'est que peut-être
avec la technologie actuelle donc les
ordinateurs et tout ça shirov a tendance
à connaître beaucoup de choses théorique
et à aimer jouer des positions pas
forcément original quelquefois mais très
théorique dans lesquelles ils arrivent
quand même à exprimer d un génie
tactique incroyable dans cette position
après le coup de joël lautier tour 8 on
peut s'attendre bien sûr à tour a eu un
de la part des blancs pour maintenir la
suprématie sur la seule colonne ouverte
pour le moment qu'est la colonne c'est
important bien sûr de contrôler avec les
tours les colonnes qui sont ouvertes
l'objectif suprême étant bien sûr
d'atteindre la septième rangée pour
essayer de dévaster
toute la phalange de pions de
l'adversaire donc probablement le
coutour à un ici va être joué la seule
chose que joël lautier peut craindre
quand même dans cette position avec les
noirs c'est les affaiblissements
surgissent hisser sur f5 qui peuvent se
révéler dangereux et aussi le pion à
chis qui peut constituer quand même une
attaque par un sacrifice direct soit fou
prend achi c'est l'arrivée de la dame
près du roi noir tout à fait d'ailleurs
on appelle un petit peu ce type
d'affaiblissement des affaiblissements
chronique ce sont des affaiblissements
qui vont évidemment comme les pions ne
peuvent pas reculer qui vont rester
toute la partie et qui vont toujours
être des facteurs très importants dans
l'évaluation de la position ça c'est
clair
donc la position promu un aspect assez
fond de court
c'est à dire les tours sont prêtes à
s'échanger à distance et tout pour
l'instant une position assez assez peu
spectaculaire mais pourtant très très
compliqué donc puisqu'il ya une
nouveauté et les joueurs donc
actuellement ça bouillonne quoi ça
bouillonne d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir un
petit peu comment comment les joueurs
sont assis sur l'échiquier donc là il
échange une tour et joël va probablement
proposer un autre échange de tours voilà
tours 7
la difficulté pour joël dans cette
position s'était de choisir le bon ordre
de coups joués tour 7 d'abord ou
échanger d'abord en e2 pour jouer tout
en recettes
la position est à mon avis à peu près
égales sans doute un petit plus pour les
blancs mais peut-être symbolique
notre numéro un français est en train de
notre espoir national est en train de
neutraliser donc
l'attaquant alex hayes et donc il aura
une vie risquent de faire match nul est
d'avoir une petite option pour cette
deuxième demi finale
oui ça quand on connaît joël avec les
pièces blanches on se dit que il a
toutes ses chances de marquer un point
avec les blancs s'il arrivait bien sûr à
attirer au moins un demi point de cette
partie cette première partie contraire
alexei shirov qui vient de jouer un coup
tout à fait logique
roy f1 il veut interdire l'accès ont eu
deux à la dame noire car la menace était
dameuse dans cette position moi ici je
pense que joël a quasiment égaliser la
seule mauvaise pièce serait le cavalier
c6 qu'il peut recycler par cavalli des
huit jouée ces six obtenir quasiment
donc une symétrie de pions il a soulagé
à la pression adverse en échangeant des
tours maintenant à mon avis le reste
était assez technique et là nul devrait
être le résultat logique de cette partie
exactement est ce que d'ailleurs où vous
pensez que les joueurs vont continuer
cette position très très longtemps
moi je pense qu'ils vont qui vont
continuer dans la mesure où par exemple
shirov quand même n'est pas menacée de
2,2 de perdre même si la position est
égal
il se doit de mettre la pression sur son
adversaire pour essayer de le faire de
le faire craquer parce qu'elle sait très
bien que de toute façon avec les pièces
noires il va souffrir contre je vais le
sait très bien préparés qui est très
très incisif continuer les pièces
blanches
d'ailleurs nous dans les matchs
importants en équipe on mais joël avec
les blonds parce qu'on sait que ça va
faire très mal à l'adversaire et souvent
il apporte le point décisif c'était le
cas contre nice et paix à nous dans le
match contre montpellier 1 une
discipline où qui a quand même été demi
finaliste du championnat du monde fis
des et joël l'a complètement pulvérisé
avec les pièces blanches donc shirov ne
sera pas à la fête
quand il aura les noirs contre joël donc
à mon avis il se doit de continuer pour
essayer de faire craquer je rêve parce
que le facteur temps peut jouer un rôle
très important
oui mais quand même cette position quand
même se font en d2 ces pièces quand même
pas très bien placé et enfin je veux
dire placer correctement mais
mandé peu de perspectives d' attaque
quand même il mais psychologiquement il
peut pas se permettre de faire nul
rapidement donc il doit continuer même
si peut-être qu'il sait déjà qu'il
n'aura aucun espoir à retirer de cette
position est un peu il est peut-être un
peu moins bien aussi non ici les nôtres
bétonneurs nationale noc
arnaud dans quelques mots sur cette
position je pense que shirov serait
satisfait du nul ici parce que je vois
vraiment rien pour les blancs le pion hd
sous pression par le des pièces noires
sont excellentes cavaliers de sept cas
il ya cinq tout lesquelles sont
contrôlées la seule colonne ouverte et
et pour les noirs donc je pense que
j'aurai elle va continuer cette position
cdc pas chirac et les expositions
si je pense qu'il ya une proposition nul
deux jours et je pense que je suis
refait accepterait immédiatement parce
que on voit vraiment rien pour les
blancs sur en plus la structure est figé
sur noir et le fouet de cases noires
donc perspectives pour les noirs plus
tôt donc voilà donc une position très
intéressante et finalement ce serait
bien que ça fasse que les joueurs
fassent une petite news rapide comme ça
ça nous permettrait d'équilibrer au
niveau des horaires on a eu un premier
match assez long et donc là en plus on
aurait quand même de fortes chances de
voir un devoir notre notre espoir
national en finale oui ça serait une
bonne chose de voir joël lautier en
finale bien sûr contre contre boris
spassky qui qui a souvent eu du mal
contre contre j'aurai un match
fantastique
à l'occasion du trophée bompard c'était
en 1980
11 je crois ou joël avait éliminé boris
spassky qui était à l'époque le numéro
un français donc un coup fou au 1
alors là je dois dire que j'ai du mal à
comprendre l'idée de ce coup sans doute
de la mode de jeu pensent ils recyclent
et son fou sur une meilleure diagonale
jean-luc ça doit être ça la
signification le monde se fout n'a plus
trop de n'arrive pas à trouver comment
dire un support sur cette diagonale ses
1 h 6 donc là peut-être dans un premier
temps ils l'anticipent parce que s'il
vient ci devient trop tôt en d3
lecavalier le cavalier noir va venir sur
quatre c'est quand même un problème on
est tout à fait moi je pense que l'idée
est plutôt de jouer dameuse d'échanger
les dames et ensuite de jouer qu'à des
traits et ils ont les deux joueurs ont
fait nul donc il fallait faire voilà
donc jean luc tu veux tu avais raison
dans cette position migros n'a pas forcé
pour les nuls dans cette première partie
se propositions des deux joueurs
on va faire une petite pause de dix
minutes avant de reprendre la deuxième
partie longue pause de 10 minutes
donc comme jean-luc chavanon l'avait
annoncé alexis gilles rof n'a pas
cherchéà a forcé dans une position sans
espoir de gain et il a préféré donc
garder son énergie pour la deuxième
partie c'est un très très bon résultat
pour pour joël lautier quand même c'est
une victoire une petite victoire c'est
une victoire psychologique et évidemment
c'est une grande victoire psychologique
puisque faire nuls en quinze coups
neutraliser son adversaire dans un match
en deux parties c'est quand même une
grande grande victoire mais bon alexei
shirov qui est le numéro quatre mondial
est très très solide avec les noirs il
est très violent si il est capable de
trouver des ressources
c'est pas encore gagné et heureusement
sûrs bien sûr c'est pas assez pas encore
gagné mais mais il va souffrir dans
l'indre dans la seconde partie parce que
joël avec les blancs comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure et très redoutable
à moins à moins que shirov est une
préparation maison pour contrer les
variantes du numéro un français en tout
cas une deuxième partie palpitante qui
va reprendre dans quelques minutes
joël lautier a donc c'est un score très
très impressionnant avec les pièces
blanches puisqu'il a 61 % de gain
positif dans toute sa carrière
ce qui bien sûr est énorme sur quand
même plus de 1000
ce en partie joué en compétition
officielle
la dernière fois que les deux joueurs se
sont affrontées c'était en partie rapide
dans le tournoi de monaco le tournoi
mélodies amber et alexei shirov avait
gagné avec avait gagné la partie rapide
espérons bien sûr que je re elle va
prendre cette va prendre sa revanche
à l'occasion de cette deuxième partie
alors nous avons aussi un autre invité
permanent qu'est le renverra qui qui
fait la sieste donc on va ça va mais il
n'y avait pas grand chose à dire sur
cette partie en fait
mission donc jean claude je voudrais
juste dire donc que le match revanche va
être très très tendue je voudrais penser
que j'ai le pronostique un petit peu les
ouvertures donc sur e4 c'est joël joue
plusieurs ouvertures ils jouent eux
quatre des cats et c4
si joël jouaux 4 je pense qu'on aura
peut-être une probablement une défense
sicilienne nador sera encore plus
probable une nage dehors oui les ventes
à la mode de toute façon sur des quatre
probablement une semi slave qui est une
ouverture très très jouée actuellement
ou chez les tops mondiaux est sûre sur
c4 c4 c'est peu probable mais pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas une surprise une
anglaise
je ne sais pas peut-être que je l aurais
envie de jouer une anglaise je ne sais
pas comment je joue shirov contre les
anglaises mais probablement une envie de
jouer dans également une slave ou tout
simplement une préparation de la part de
shirov dans ce cas là on peut s'attendre
à n'importe quelle ouverture comme
l'estonienne pourquoi pas une ouverture
qui qui a du punch comme comme la benko
pourquoi pas le même qu'au
le bento sera peut-être le bentô c'est
incroyable de temps en temps shirov
joola grünfeld ce qui est très très
dynamique mais bon il la dernière partie
qu'ils ont joué ensemble
sérieuse je crois s'était mué en 33 non
une quarantaine de coups c'était une
grande fête où ils ont joué 32 coup de
théorie
c'était incroyable jean-claude oui moi
je parierais plutôt sur une green side
dans cette dans cette deuxième partie
parce que les deux joueurs sont très
affûtés sur cette variante joël avec les
blancs et shirov avec les noirs lors de
leur dernière partie classique c'était
cette ouverture et je serais pas du tout
étonnée qu'il qu'il rejoue le même début
avec une petite préparation pour l'un ou
pour l'autre donc moi je parie plutôt
sur une grünfeld donc une grünfeld donc
les paris sont lancés
donc je rappelle donc un aux
téléspectateurs de canal web donc nous
sommes en direct de la salle médicis du
sénat donc nous assistons donc à la
deuxième demi finale du du grand prix du
sénat canal web donc un tournoi donc et
qui est sponsorisé par la banque
populaire est aussi l'hôtel raphaël est
donc un a loué le sénat est donc la
première demi finale la première
demi-finale s'est soldée par la victoire
donc de boris spassky sur le sort sur le
score de 3 points à 2 donc une finale
très très attendu puisqu'il a fallu
passer au penalty donc et dans la séance
des penaltys des tirs au but boris l'a
emporté par 2 but à 1
donc voilà donc deux victoires à une
pour boris qui a fait donc deux matchs
nuls et qui a gagné l'année la partie
évidemment c'était une blague
ce n'est pas du foot c'est des échecs
voilà donc actuellement et donc dans la
deuxième demi finale la première partie
s'est soldée par là nul donc c'était une
défense
c'était une espagnole une partie
espagnole une très vieille ouverture qui
fait partie des plus vieilles partie des
plus vielles d'ouverture qui existe dans
le jeu d'échecs plus que l'espagnol date
du du 15e siècle je crois ou du 16e et
qu'elle a été inventé par rui lopez qui
était espagnole
donc voila et donc nous
nous avons le plaisir donc de poser
quelques questions quelques impressions
donc à notre josé nationale donc josé eu
quelques mots donc sur sur cet événement
donc josé de sousa qui était un
animateur donc un présentateur de canal
web de diagonale est qui et qui est là
parmi nous donc j'osais je suis je suis
assez impressionné ils ont arrêté puis
ma bonjour je suis assez impressionné
disons par le niveau des partis et c'est
suite à des questions donc mais aussi
les décès les questions attention les
réponses
la spécialité de josé les questions mais
bon cette fois donc josé dans des camps
une cette ouverture toi qui es lesquels
et on répond qu'est-ce que tu joues jose
avec avec les blancs mal tu joues e cat
ou des cats le 4e 4 4 donc tu joues au 4
et donc est ce que tu connais un petit
peu tu connais bien l'espagnol non je
crois que mais je pense aussi peut-être
que chez rough à une nouveauté en fait
mais il voudrait pas la placer dans un
semi rapide il préférait attendre toi
linares ou un grand tournoi pour plaider
sa nouveauté et donc il se dit bon ici
bon tant pis si je vais pas davantage
pas grave la prochaine je fais nul et
puis tous décidons blitz donc comme ça
et garde ses cartouches pour un tournoi
futures plus important disons que qu'un
événement qui pour lui et tu penses que
donc hélas des armes secrètes en devises
ont tous des armes secrètes et ne révèle
pas je pense d'ailleurs oui johnny n'a
révélé in pour faire nul mais un oui
c'est possible de l'authie a sorti une
arme secrète parce qu'il a besoin
finalement sur son terrain à domicile
avec son public et il a besoin quand
même deux de marquer le coup quoi je
veux dire de s'imposer c'est quelque
chose de légitime et donc donc on
comprend qu'il est sorti une ouverture
qu'il connaît très très bien et
peut-être que pour lui finalement il
montre pas grand chose disons que il
connaît très bien cette position il a
fait longtemps qu'il veut montrer à
shirov que sur quatre il est prêt il est
solide et en plus il a trouvé une
position qui handicape bien son
adversaire
oui je
je suis tout à fait d'accord il on a une
histoire c'est vrai que je suis rom fils
il a rien à perdre mais disons il est le
favori et puis c'est shirov cvo loti qui
doit prouver que mon mât que chez lui il
est plus fort que gérant fait je pense
que et tu sais d'ailleurs que certains
joueurs gardent des nouveautés pour des
parties rapides donc non mais ce cas
manquer j'en ai pas non mais est ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il y a des
nouveautés qui sont spécialisés dans les
parties sérieuse ou les parties rapides
et d'autres nouveautés pour les blitz
donc tu pense qu'il peut y avoir des
bluffs pour les parties rapides
exactement exactement qu'est ce que t'en
pense jean claude bajeux pense que c'est
tout à fait vrai dans la mesure où
maintenant dans les matches au plus haut
niveau notamment le championnat du monde
la nouvelle formule dont qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas les départage
peuvent se faire fin dans beaucoup de
grands tournois les départage peut se
faire en partie rapide donc c'est bien
d'avoir des armes secrètes
je passe sur le championnat du monde les
partages face d'ailleurs en partie
parties rapides mais si ces messieurs et
gagne le match narbonne à lausanne
oui
m
voilà alors on va on va redémarrer donc
on va démarrer cette seconde partie de
cette seconde demi finale
donc là je vais lautier va voir les
blancs donc
s'il s'il gagne il gagnera le droit de
participer à la finale de demain qui je
vous rappelle aura lieu à 14h30 alors
que la première petite finale aura lieu
elle à 10h30 demain matin donc il faudra
se lever un peu tôt si vous voulez
assister au match
donc j'appelle pour cette deuxième
partie d'abord le numéro un français
joël lautier
et donc son adversaire numéro quatre
mondial actuel alexei shirov
voilà je la salle arbitre le swan
démarré la partie bien la deuxième
partie entre ces deux très grands
champions va commencer dans quelques
instants
donc larbitre sacha la desigual à des
cats comme plus ou moins imprévue c4 et
je pense que nous allons nous diriger
vers une grünfeld avec la grande
variante avec damas cinq échecs et dame
prend à deux voix là c'est les deux
joueurs ont entamé leurs débats
théoriques il y à quelques temps à nant
joël lautier change il joue dame b 3 et
wii dame b3 qui est l'autre variante à
la mode actuellement dont on joue soit
la grande ligne avec pu reprendre des
cinq soit dame b 3 donc cette ouverture
qui est qu'ils aient joué par les
meilleurs joueurs du monde et dans
laquelle kasparov a souvent eu des
difficultés avec les noirs oui oui c'est
scène c'est un début qui est très
tranchant et c'est le dernier système à
la mode contre pour lutter contre la
gangrène qui es tu est un début quand
même très incisif et qui permet au noir
de marque est souvent le point anti l'un
des grands spécialistes d'ailleurs de
cette ouverture c'est le hollandais et
entraîneurs aussi de joël août ils
travaillent tous les deux ensemble
le vent nous a dit oui je crois que
c'est une spécialité hollandaise parce
que le premier joueur hollandais qui a
joué sept variantes et qui a battu garry
kasparov s'est aussi y aura une pie 4
qui a battu garry kasparov en jouant
cette ligne et je me souviens de
l'anecdote c'est que gary avait dit
avait dit que dans ses analyses dans ces
notes il y avait la réputation et parce
qu'il a il était tellement quand on dire
vexés d'avoir perdu cette partie qu'il a
voulu prouver au grand public que qu'il
avait raison donc fou g4 tous les
meilleurs joueurs de la planète jouent
maintenant la grüne fun on peut voir une
kasparov et aussi peter l'écho qu'il
ajouterait régulièrement qui a fait nul
assez tranquillement sur ce système il
n'ya pas longtemps peut-être à linares
contre kasparov lui même attention ça
chauffe donc cavalier f17 et grand roque
donc là il se passe des choses
incroyables donc un développement très
très tranchants les blancs qui sont
prêts à doubler leurs pions en f3 ce
n'est pas très important un coup
cavaliers avaient 17 qu'il faut
expliquer c'est à dire le cavalier donc
ce repli
pour dégager la grande diagonale il se
dirige sur b6 et les noirs vont essayer
donc d'avoir une action sur le centre
plus soutenu donc principalement parce
que le fou en g7 sera plus actif
donc là actuellement les noirs sont en
pleine réflexion
oui moi ce que je voulais dire jean luc
eux dans cette position c'est la
première fois que je l oti joue cette
variante avec les blancs alors que il
joue habituellement la grande variantes
et où il ya quand même des scores à tout
à fait impressionnant 71 % et 67 % de
résultats positifs donc s'ils changent
c'est qu'il vraiment il a une idée très
intéressante à jouer avec les blancs et
sans doute il va nous gratifier d'une
partie fantastique voit la réaction au
centre donc les noirs réagissent tout de
suite au centre est exactement donc ils
font intervenir leurs fous j'ai sept sur
sept grandes diagonales la diagonale h 8
à 1
immédiatement donc pour l'instant une
position très tranchantes
donc joël en pleine concentration et que
va-t-il faire donc sur par exemple puis
on prend le 5
je ne connais pas très bien la théorie
je prends ce que sur pied reprend 1,5
les noirs devraient dans cette position
peut-être prendre en reste 3 et prendre
le pion aux 5
je ne sais pas je pense que oui ça
semble normal
oui tout à fait jean-luc c'est
effectivement la suite la suite qu'il
faut envisager
je vais regarder bien sûr s'il y a eu
des partis récentes qui ont été jouées
sur ce thème mais il ya fort à parier vu
la vitesse à laquelle joël à jouer ce
début et notamment grand roc qu'il a
quand même une préparation maison il
faut l'espérer parce que il prend
énormément de risques il faut voir que
c'est une partie revanche que joël a
gagné avec les avec les blancs et donc
là il tente le tout pour le tout et dans
ce type de position l'annuler peu
probable je pense si bien sûr il peut y
avoir une nulle part un échec perpétuel
ou non je pense que il prend des risques
il a raison si le s'il veut éliminer
shirov de toute façon il devra prendre
des risques ça fait partie du jeu il
peut pas se contenter
il peut pas se contenter de la deûle
annuler parce qu'il sait très bien que
en blitz tout peut arriver et il doit
prendre des risques dans cette partie
pour essayer de l'emporter on que les
noirs viennent de jouer les blancs ont
fermé la position par des quatre des
cinq événements viennent de jouer
cavalier b6 donc attaquant madame donc
la dame va probablement
bouger sur peut-être la case b3 ou la
case bekkat je pense plutôt p3 puisque
les noirs doivent trouver une réaction
dans cette position ferme et la position
est une idée intéressante puisque ça ça
a tendance à conduire à en fermer
définitivement le fou en g7 qui n'aura
plus plu autant d'activités et oui juste
le coup cavalli b6 dans cette position
est éteint et un coup nouveau qui n'a
jamais été joué le coup une partie entre
deux hollandais
quand tu disais que les hollandais
étaient les spécialistes de cette
variante était le coup c7 c6 la
maintenance coût va être un peu plus
problématique pour les noirs à cause
bien sûr du vis-à-vis de la tour des uns
et de la dame en des huit voies la dame
b 3 jean-luc bon la position va être
très très compliqué mais il semble quand
même que les blancs est une bonne
position
les blancs sont un peu mieux les blancs
sont un peu mieux développer et tout
donc là pour l'instant difficile de
faire des pronostics puisque le les
noirs n'ont pas encore montré clairement
leurs plans leur stratégie donc le temps
actuellement donc le temps des blancs et
2 21e 28e minute et quarante ans il
reste 21 minutes et 43 secondes au blanc
quant au noir il leur reste un peu plus
22 minutes et 3 secondes donc un
contrôle temps très très équilibré et
donc pour l'instant des petites chances
blanche oui c'est toujours le match qui
commence bien en fin match leur tour qui
commence bien pour le joueur français
nous allons profiter peut-être d'un
petit temps mort pour la partie pour
interviewé jacques rosselin qui est le
pdg de canal web et qui nous a rejoints
en cabine donc on peut lui demander ses
premières impressions sur ce trophée
canal web
voilà une belle partie g1 j'ai une
petite tristesse pour aux sharks était
le coup de coeur canal web et qui a
tenté sa chance contre spassky qui a été
remarquable contre un champion de cette
catégorie et mais j'espère qu'on le
reverra bientôt sur sur le circuit
callaway puis on peut appeler ça comme
ça alors que représente pour vous pour
canal web le jeu d'échecs
voilà canal web ont fait de la
télévision thématiques à attention ça
joue là donc j'étais heureux laisser la
parole aux commentaires non ont fait de
la télévision thématiques et les échecs
c'est vraiment notre notre émission
phare bien jean-luc alors il ya eu une
séquence de jeu donc à 5 tout à fait
logique
il faut essayer de gagner de l'espace
et puis où vous essayez aussi de mettre
en jeu pourquoi pas la tour à 8 et poser
une question à la dame qui était quand
même très bien placés en b3 elle se
retrouve en c2 qui est une moins bonne
case et en même temps le pion en acat ce
qu'on appelle fixe les la structure de
pions blanche allèles dame le pion à 3
et et le pion b2 ce qui dans la finale
bien sûr pas dans l'immédiat mais en
finale peut être un désavantage pour les
blancs il me le pion à 4 quand même doit
être défendu il faut quand même se
méfier donc il faut toujours garder des
pièces pour contrôler ce pion d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que je joue elle a joué à
troyes très finement pour éviter par
exemple a4 a3 qui qui affaiblirait
définitivement la position le roc blanc
donc joël qui qui créent et qui
consolide son son rock c'est à dire sa
position de roi al dam est donc là
alexei qui décide finalement donc de
casser les règles ils préfèrent plutôt
que d'ouvrir la position au centre
puisque actuellement il n'est peut-être
pas assez bien développée pour ouvrir au
centre et préfère d'avoir développé ces
pièces et je pense qu'il va peut être
essayer de transférer peut-être en
développant sa dame et la tour et fuites
et si la transférer sur ces 8 pour jouer
un coup comme celle ci
je pense qu'il a d'abord envie de sortir
ces pièces avant d'effectuer une
quelconque réaction au centre oui une
autre possibilité aussi pour ce cavalier
c'est de se diriger vers la case b3
peut-être après dames 7 et cavaliers c5
voilà donc bien sûr joël loties elles
jouent et roye b 1 qui est un coup
prophylactique importance il est clair
que le roi en c1 sera mal placé dans le
cas notamment d'une éventuelle ouverture
de la colonne c est le roi doit se
réfugier sur le côté où il sera beaucoup
plus en sécurité ce qui peut aussi
permettre aux blancs de récupérer cette
colonne en jouant tour des c1 et pour
faire pression sur le pion c'est cet te
fais donc c'est un gros classiques donc
on place le roi l'a donc les joueurs
jouent cette position de façon ultra
classique bon la position la structure
est assez contrairement à ce qu'on a eu
dans la partie d'avant elle n'est pas
symétrique est ce qui est d'autant plus
intéressant donc il y a un peu près
symétrie sauf le pion des 5 contre le
pion c7 et le fait que les rock les rois
soient placés sur des sur des sur des
ailes opposées donc un le roi blanc
allèles dame leroy noah le roi noir
allaient les leroy été tuée est un
facteur très intéressant qui fait que la
partie va être d'autant plus compliquée
et combative oui ça va saigner les
parties avec des rocs opposé en général
sont très animées l'a d'ailleurs souvent
ce qui compte c'est l'ouverture des
lignes pour ça on est prêt à sacrifier
des pions du côté où on veut attaquer le
roi et on serait même très content par
exemple si les noirs n'avaient pas le
pion bessette ou le pion ses sets car il
pourrait attaquer à l école ouverte
et bien sûr si les blancs avaient la
colonne h ouverte une chose peut être
dans cette position shirov réfléchi
peut-être à la perspective de jouer l5
donc tu penses à f/5 donc une réaction
intéressante pour éventuellement jouer
f4 pour fermer la position est pour pour
dominer le centre ou pour attaquer ce
puisse être case cap peut-être non tout
simplement pour miner le centre et le
pion
le pion que 4 le faire disparaître pour
affaiblir le pion des 5 qui serait qui
se retrouverait son sens défenseur sans
pions pour le défendre donc une
faiblesse potentielle on va dire quand
on est une chaîne de pions comme c'est
le cas ici des 5,4 si on veut affaiblir
le pion des cinq est quand même bien
ancrée dans la position noir et qui pose
quelques problèmes ville est de bonne
guerre d'affaiblir la base d'attaqué la
bad il dit une décision grave puisque
après f5
on peut on peut éventuellement peut-être
même prendre un f5 ou ou développer des
pièces non c'est 6 il a décidé d'ouvrir
la position maintenant maintenant il a
développé suffisamment bien ces pièces
et il ouvre il ouvre un petit peu un
petit peu les dames puisque s'y joue
elle prend le pion ans et 6 il reprend
du plombier et ouvre automatiquement la
colonne b
donc la colonne béquilles et qui
évidemment est très très utile pour une
tour qui pourrait éventuellement exercé
une pression incroyable sur le pion b2
donc beaucoup d'actions après peut-être
un coup intéressant serait de jouer des
six la seule chose qui paraît un petit
peu embêtante c'est l'arrivée du fou
réussissent maintenant qu'ils pourraient
ensuite pourquoi pas aller en b3 mais
peut-être que le coût des six est
intéressant justement pour essayer de
fermer le jeu puis on aurait pu on
passait oui tout à fait oui je pense que
des 6 es tu un coup vraiment un candidat
très important puisque après les noirs
se retrouverait avec un des petits
problèmes de coordination entre l'ale
dames et les droits
d'ailleurs joël réfléchit beaucoup dans
cette position laisser prendre en d5 est
peut-être possible aussi mais je pense
que des si c'est une décision
intéressante il faut il faut réfléchir à
ce qu'on va peut-être commencer un petit
peu à calculer des six sur des sicilia
fou réussissent faut aussi ce qui est
dangereux il met peut-être surtout s'ils
sont peu joué cavalier d2 tout
simplement pour contrôler la casse b3 et
ça peut être intéressant évidemment
parce que la menace s'est évidemment je
tiens à rappeler c'était sûr faut ici
c'était tout simplement fou b3 qui
attaque et la dame en c2 et la tour en
d1 et donc qui aurait gagné une qualité
donc fou aussi ce tu proposes cavaliers
des deux et maintenant on peut peut-être
essayer de d'une certaine manière
d'attaquer ce pion ce pion deux des six
ans jouant par exemple c'est pas facile
parce que le problème c'est qu'on est
assez embouteillée ce qu'on appelle
embouteillée c'est à dire que les pièces
les pièces les pièces noires ont des
problèmes pour pour s'activer plus pour
peut-être d'amd 8 faut aussi skalli d2
et d'un v8 pour attaquer le plan des six
alors peut-être jean-luc que vous
pourriez nous expliquer ce qu'est gagner
la qualité pour les néophytes qui nous
écoutent tout à fait d'en gagner la
qualité c'est tout simplement prendre
une tour avec un fou ou un cavalier
puisque le fou et cavaliers sont des
pièces mineurs l'outil a choisi de jouer
h3c en fait c'est à mon pote donc dans
cette position shirov à jouer h3 donc
pour se débarrasser du foot case blanche
puisque peut-être il a après death is
fuoh si c'était quelque chose d'assez
désagréable donc ils préfèrent prendre
ce fou et jouer avec leur père de fou
donc on va dans cette position avoir un
combat entre entre des cavaliers et des
fous un combat vraiment réel je crois
donc les cavaliers qui quand même
contrôle quelques cases du fou puisque
cahier b6 empêche le fou le fonds afin
de venir sur cette jolie case sekkat sur
lesquels il serait très très bien
installés ils contrôleraient centre et
il permet d'y serait développé
complètement mais en même temps bon les
huiles et blanc ont toujours la
possibilité de deux poussées au centre
ils ont une masse au centre supérieur
une masse de pions supérieure alors le
dernier coup de shirov était un petit
peu obligé parce que les blancs menacé
en fait de gagner une
jean-luc on menaçait de prendre en c6 et
puis de prendre en b6 avec le fouet si
la dame prend le cavalier rester en
prison 17 et bien sûr le cavalier ne
pouvait pas reprendre en b 6 à cause de
la dame qui était perdu en dix huit donc
le coût d'un même si c'est un très bon
coup il perd mais bon la taille du pion
f3 je pense pas que ce soit réellement
dangereux bien comment faudra peut-être
quand même vérifier mais surtout la dame
part de ceux de ce vis-à-vis tour dames
qui pouvaient maintenant s'avérer
désagréable tout à fait et en plus les
noirs font ce qu'on appelle comment dire
ils coordonnent leur tour c'est-à-dire
les tours communique actuellement il
libère un petit peu la tour et fuites
non qu'ils ont ils augmentent leur
potentiel leur potentiel donc les pièces
sont plus actifs dans cette position à
noter quand même que robert m'a signalé
un petit piège donc h4 dans cette
position h4 qui menacerait tout
simplement de piquer la dame donc que la
joie elle joue dames 2 mai sur h4h si
c'était possible
oui et puis aussi sur sur h4 gagner la
dame par fou g5 c'était ça mais on avait
encore d'am dam c-50 d'amd 6 tout à fait
mais ça devenait risqué puisque là on se
retrouvait en vis-à-vis avec la tour en
d1 donc dame eu deux coups intéressants
donc actuellement les la position
allèles dame est très très verrouillé ce
qui est très important et les blancs qui
n'ont pas une très bonne structure pour
l'instant mais ont la possibilité
éventuellement de à n'importe quel
moment de dédoubler leurs pions et
d'obtenir quelque chose donc une
position encore très très tendue jean
lui que je vous repose de passer la
parole à
arnaud hauchard qui suit la partie dans
la cabine à nos côtés et qui peut nous
donner peut-être ses impressions sur
cette position
oui il ne semble que les noirs sont bien
mais le pion 1,4 peut toujours être
faiblesse en finale donc je pense que je
suis rva prendre en d5 parce que c'est
si des six est toujours un peu gênant je
pense qu il faut qu il ouvre le jeu qui
prennent la casse et 400 cavaliers dire
extra tegick pour les noirs sont bien
mais il faut il faut il faut faire
attention la finale quand il faut pas
rentrer en finale
vu que il me semble quand même que les
blancs ont un petit avantage dans cette
position enfin moi je préfère on a les
deux fous dans une position quand même
qui va s'ouvrir
on a un candidat puis ont passé ce qui
est une bonne chose en vue de la finale
le seul petit problème c'est un problème
de structure on a le pion à trois qui
peut être faible et le pion et le pion
f3 qui bien sûr est une faiblesse
relative je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez
bob il faut pas oublier que si le fouet
fuite s'échange contre le faux ou trois
parfois ces cinq et quinze minutes 43
donc à joël lautier toujours très
équilibré donc la position est tendue en
position blanche est quand même
préférable puisque le foot case blanche
va va peut-être apparaître en h3 et
ainsi va trouver de l'activité ou même
h5 pour forcer un peu les blancs les
noirs à ouvrir un peu le roi est sûre
j'ai cinq fois je crois maintenant
contrôlant toutes les cases blanches
la position dynamique du terroir
avantage un petit peu les noirs je pense
qu'ils sont mieux protégés que parce que
l'a3 à trois bébés 2 ça peut être faible
aussi fou et fuite
tu penses que le fou n'a rien à faire en
g7 en fuite il peut être efficace qui
peut des fois chez et s'échanger en
cessant et que les cases noires quand
même moi je pense qu'il ya pas de
problème pour les noirs je vois pas de
plan pour les blancs là parce que si on
joue à chaque g5 que je vois pas
ok on va avoir le fourrage 3 et après ça
ne contrôle pas vraiment c4 et puis
petit il est une petite pression sur la
colonne des cc pas qu'elle est encore
bien donc nous en sommes après ce coup à
chis c'est a donc alexis à joël lautier
de de jouer c'est pas facile de trouver
un coup quand même dans cette position
on peut envisager il ya un coup simple
entre guillemets c'est le coup foufou h3
le fou trouvera une excellente une
excellente diagonale et puis bon bien
sûr le pion h4 ne seraient pas en prison
ce qui serait cauchemardesque pour les
pour les noirs à cause de la prison 17
et la dame serait attaqué en h4 par la
touvre h un mois j'opterais h5 g5 et l'a
donc actuellement à 12,5 kg cinq ont été
joués donc toujours les mêmes
possibilités joël affirmer la position
mais ils obtiennent des cases blanches
il obtient plus de cash blanche donc
probablement sa annonce son coût fou fou
h3 fouet fuites qui ont été jouées
actuellement donc joue elle prend les
cases blanches
alexei prend les cannois on peut dire
cette position et est peut-être au petit
avantage blanc mais c'est une position
en complet déséquilibre c'est à dire que
que la structure est très curieuse et
que les pièces sont des activités un
petit peu d'hiver c'est à dire le fou
qui va s'avérer sur f5 lors des
positions de rock très bloquée quelques
casses contrôlé quelques cases noires en
c5 et cette diagonale contrôlée par le
fouet fuite
donc les activités des pièces et est
tellement
diverses que il est difficile d'évaluer
clairement cette position oui et puis en
plus c'est à joël de jouer il a un petit
retard au temps il a trois minutes de
retard
il ne doit pas être évident de trouver
un coup un bon plan dans cette position
avec les blancs parce que la position et
est assez complexe
peut-on envisager une attaque sur la
colonne j'ai par exemple tout à fait je
pense qu' il faudrait peut-être aller
dans cette direction
peut-être que tôt ou tard il y aura
peut-être nécessiter de sacrifier
peut-être qu est ce que tu en penses
et c'est oui moi je pensais je pensais à
des possibilités de ce type
effectivement sacrifier sur sur la
colonne g jean-luc
vous qui êtes un attaquant réputé est ce
que vous sentez des possibilités
d'attaqué pour les blancs dans cette
position peut-être mais bon la voie de
la sagesse peut être aussi serait de
prendre ces 6es de jouer sur la colonne
des il est encore possible de le faire
et je pense que c'est très très solide
aussi et de finalement d'essayer de
transposer dans des finales ou où tout
est possible puisque ce fourrage 3 peut
très bien défendre à n'importe quel
moment les pions alsh et f3 et h5 y sont
faibles
en même temps il peut attaquer le pion à
4 donc une grande souplesse en jeu blanc
je n'aime pas du tout la prise en c6 à
cause de l'ouverture de la colonne b qui
risque de poser de graves problèmes au
roi blanc avec l'arrivée du fou sur la
diagonale f 8 à 3 il y aurait des thèmes
tactique et le pion b2 serait quand même
très faible parce qu'il est fixé par le
pion à 4 il peut pas bouger et je pense
que la prison c6 permettrait au noir
d'obtenir vraiment une attaque il est
très difficile à mon avis de trouver un
implant actif ici sans prendre des
risques énormes
oui oui les blancs peuvent peut-être
préparé le terrain en jouant autour des
2 pour ensuite menacer de prononcer si
c'est doublé sur la colonne départs tour
hd 1
mais les noirs pourrait répliquer
partout sur tours d2 par cavalli c5
obligeant un peu les blancs à prendre
des décisions rapides l'on voit que les
cavaliers noirs sont un peu paralysé en
parler par la paire de foot blanche
donc il n'est pas facile pour les blancs
de créer un plan mais pour les noirs non
pluie c'est un jeu un peu de fond de
court comme tu as dit tour des deux
cavaliers ces cinq peut-être tour des
deux pouces et 5 non tu ne tu n'aimes
pas échanger les fous parce que après
cavalli c'est ça qu'on va toujours des
problèmes avec ses cavaliers on ne sait
pas comment harmoniser ce jeu de pièces
puisque si le cavalier ça ne peut pas
quitter la casse et c'est à cause du
cavalier b6 donc le cavalier bécistes
bouger et surfe ou c5 est ce que tu me
fasses quelque chose par exemple si je
double les tours
est ce que si tu prends 3 tu renforce ma
structure de pions j'ai je ramène un
pion supions prend 1,3 donne
encore un petit plus pour les blancs
peut-être mais peut-être qu'on élimine
affaire de fous dans la difficulté dans
cette position c'est de trouver un plan
actifs tour d2 effectivement et
peut-être le coup intéressant rebond
joël a choisi fou g4 qui est plus à mon
avis un coude attente il a passé
beaucoup de deux temps quand même sur
cette position il lui reste moins de dix
minutes
maintenant pour le reste de la partie
sans doute il veut aussi le libérer
saddam qui étaient scotchés à la défense
du pion f3 et comme le fou c'est un set
un coup intéressant un qui ne qui ne
prend aucun engagement on va dire et qui
passe la main au noir qui doivent eux
aussi trouver quelque chose d'actifs oui
donc un coup quand même assez difficile
à expliquer quand même j'en ai
l'impression quand même que tours d2 et
est le coup le plus naturel quand même
pour continuer l'activité
c'est fou j'ai 4 pourrait s'expliquer si
ici les blancs avaient un besoin de
bouger cette dame 2 donc il faut
chercher un petit peu comment la dame
pourrait bouger peut-être que on devenir
sur ces deux mais je ne crois pas
c'est curieux quand même bouger 4 je
pense que je suis un peu sceptique ouais
moi je pense comme jean-claude c1 c'est
vraiment un pur coup d'attentes
il protège les pions f-35 on sait jamais
plus tard quand je sais papa retour des
deux dames d1 mais il attend c'est clair
il attend de voir ce que va faire
et puis il fallait prendre une décision
jean luc le temps le temps passe et
visiblement joël n'a pas trouvé
deux plans suffisamment clair pour
progresser donc qui décide d'attendre
c'est un coût qui ne prend aucun
engagement
je pense que la position est très très
très difficile tout le monde peut s'en
rendre compte et il est difficile de
trouver quelque chose d'ailleurs shirov
réfléchit déjà depuis deux minutes après
fou gk parce qu'il est également dans le
même cas de figure
je pense que celui qui fait quelque
chose prend des risques
un petit peu à considérer peut-être que
vous avez raison de toute façon après
fou j'ai 4 ans cad des changes massives
de pièces les blancs pourraient plus
facilement libérer leurs dames comme je
les dis donc par exemple si des pièces
échangées sur la colonne des par ci par
là
les blancs pour rejouer coup comme d'âme
des uns après quelques échanges et
attaquer le pion à 4 sans se soucier du
pion f3 donc de toutes façons c'est un
coup c'est un coup très utile sans toi
est ce qu'on pourrait jouer tous ses
sens qu'ici il a joué tous ses singles
et donc fou ces cinq pour échanger les
fous et comme l'a dit robert peut-être
qu'il ne faut pas prendre ces cinq il
faut laisser faire les choses donc il
prend ses six d'abord maintenant après
fou ces cinq quand même ça se justifie
un petit peu plus de prendre ces six
parce que la colonne des il peut y avoir
de l'attak bien sûr pour les noirs mais
ils feraient semblablement les fous de
gaz nous avons vont s'échanger donc y
aura moins de pression sur le pion à 3
peut-être alors ici comment reprendre
ans et 6 puis on prend 6,6 à l'air
naturel puisque ça comptera une fois de
plus la casse des 5 et ouvrir la colonne
b pour les noirs mais dame prend 6,6 est
ce que dame prend si je peux être
vraiment grave
l'un prend 6,6 cavaliers des cinq
peut-être jean-luc oui de toute façon le
puis on prend ces 6es naturel pas d'un
point de vue structurel mais d'un point
de vue profiler ans et prophylactiques
puisque pur procès si c'était jouer mais
provoquions process control la casse des
cinq donc évite toute activité des
pièces noires dans cette position donc
pure processus en cours logique en plus
la colonne baisse est ouvert aux tomates
s'est ouverte automatiquement
donc les noirs sont très actifs mais les
blancs ont quelques en même des chances
structurelles ici tout
alors complètement justifiée pour faire
une pression supplémentaire sur le
cavalier 17 mois je pense qu'il ya un
bon avantage blanc sont robert sur tours
d2 peut-être qu'il y a fou des cats
c'est exact
pour effectuer une pression sur le
cavaly ces trois peut-être tour des
trois plus précis alors mais fou des
quatre encore oui food et 4 tout
simplement pour installer le fou au
centre et ensuite enchaîné par ces cinq
donc un coup un coup le très très
logique donc il faut se méfier
évidemment dans cette position comme on
l'a expliqué tout à l'heure les blancs
contrôler les cases blanches avec leurs
fous g4 qui est très très bien installés
sur cases blanches et les noirs qui ont
beaucoup d'eux qu'ils ont sur noir le
contrôle avec leurs fous ces cinq très
très bien les cases noires donc et
surtout cette case centrale des cats un
meilleur contrôle des quatre centrales
pour une mauvaise structure non les
noirs ici clairement comme anvers
l'indiqué menace fou des cats avec le
suivi de cavaliers c5 ce qui peut être
bien sûr très très dangereux pour les
blancs tour des deux fous des cats et
même les noirs on peut estimer ont
pratiquement l'avantagent robert e
tout à fait alors peut-être il faut il
faut maintenant jouer d'une manière un
peu plus radicale
peut-être faire fou prend ses 5 suivi
d'un bo3 pour contrôler les quinze mois
mais il restera encore tour des quatre
donc poussé 5 et un bon plan trouvé par
shirov jallet proposer le coup calleo et
cajou et joël je pense qu'il faut se
débarrasser de ce cavalier en 17 qui
allait venir en c5 et poser de graves
problèmes à mesure aussi où le fourgon
gk n'était pas très actif
je pense que j'aurai la pris une
excellente décision ici car il menaçait
peut-être d'être moins bien si l'échangé
pas les pièces tafer mais il y avait une
tactique surtout prend 17 aussi c'est
qu'après cavaliers prend 17 les blancs
pouvaient jouer tout reprend 17 et
gagner du matériel puisque après tout
prend 17 le fou de 3 prenez en c5 donc
fou prend le 3 et forcé hélas les blancs
ont le choix de placer un coup
intermédiaires comme si vous ces six
pour essayer de gagner avions oui bien
sûr fou c'est si c'est très très bien
dans cette position on peut jouer poussé
si si si on prend dans le iii d'abord
d'en prendre trois cavaliers prend 17
août et forcé est donc là maintenant il
est où tout va tout va tout va compter
sur la colonne des sur le contrôle de la
colonne des peut-être à cet instant donc
peut-être que là maintenant il va
falloir jouer cette tour des 1
en d3 plutôt grand et pur f3 plus tard
en d3 par exemple des trois tours d un
suivi des dames d2 et là comme dans la
partie d'avant les noirs vont peut-être
essayé d'échanger les les tours dans
cette position en bougeant leurs
cavaliers par exemple sur les fuites au
retour des deux a été joué maintenant
peut-être joué cavalier f8 avec l'idée
d'un mille cavaliers ont eu six où il
aura d'excellents de cases fkt des cats
voyez tout à fait donc par exemple
cavaliers fuite pour faire un petit peu
comme dans la partie d'avant dont
cavaliers fuite était joué et donc
maintenant les blancs ont la possibilité
de doubler les tours mais donc après la
finale est quand même assez dur et
évaluer puisque le pion à 4 et tout tout
tout isolé mais al elle allait le roi
les les pions blancs ne sont pas très
bons cavaliers aussi ça a été joué dans
ce type de position jean-luc les
cavaliers quand il ya des structures
quand même disloqué comme ça sont sont
assez forts je pense que lecavalier
noir est supérieur au cavalier blanc
dans cette position et en plus la
structure de pions des blancs ne
favorise pas cette chose je pense que
les noirs ont peut-être un petit
avantage ici probable dans cette
position les noirs ont un petit avantage
mais par exemple que se passerait-il
après tout reprend des huit tours prend
des 8 et par exemple tour c'est un pur
tout simplement attaqué le pion à 4 donc
dans ce cas là tu permettrait qu'à
valider quatre avec la date du pur f3
donc peut-être vaut mieux qu'il contrôle
et à la case et 4 par carey lieu de
jouer un peu plus prudent alors il ya
aussi une suite qui serait il ya un
piège en fait avec cavalli aussi ce tour
prend des huit tours prend des huit
tours prend dès 8 ans fred d'amendé hui
pour des six a été joué donc tour des
six est là donc joël qui essayent de
compenser donc donc le le fait que le
cavalier aussi c'est très bien
positionné il y avait là des avants
postes pour
donc il le clou déjà le cas mais ne peut
pas bouger et en plus ils attaquent le
pion c6 oui tout à fait tout à fait
jean-luc donc après après tour des six
on peut peut-être envisagée c'est un
coup c'est un coup assez ennuyeux par
une tour des six ont peut-être envisagé
autour c8 tout simplement
mais à ce moment-là peut-être que le
pion le pion à 4 serait emprise
peut-être tour des six pose un problème
et si on échangeait tout simplement non
aurait cédé la colonne des donc ça c'est
pas du tout une bonne une bonne chose
tour des six est un excellent coup
trouvé par par joël lautier attention
aux jo elle n'a plus que cinq minutes 39
pour terminer la partie alors qu'alexei
à 11 minutes 30
donc alexei est nettement mieux au temps
joël a réussi à résoudre ses problèmes
pour l'instant mais la position qui est
très complexe va probablement
être riche en nouvelles en nouvelles
ressources donc
donc il va falloir qu'ils accélèrent et
qu'il soit comment dire incapable de
trouver les bons coups au bon moment
mais bon on a tout à fait confiance il
faut il faut trouver maintenant un coup
alors six tours à ses huit peut-on
prendre deux pions en a quatre est ce
que c'est une une bonne une bonne chose
il me semble un tour à ses huit ont fait
cavaliers prend 1,4 et on a gagné un pur
tout simplement pour dc 8 donc alexei
donc défend le pion c6 est donc joël
maintenant à la lourde responsabilité de
de trouver un plan donc là je rappelle
que dans cette position cavaliers des
cinq ne marche pas cavalier des cinq qui
étaient tout simplement tour des deux
tours d1 d2 donc tour d2 donc les blancs
comme tout à l'heure tiennent leurs
positions et maintenant les noirs vont
devoir trouver le plan donc je joue elle
qui décide finalement de jouer des coups
sûrs et d'accélérer un petit peu le le
timing peut être peut on peut peut-être
maintenant rejouer tour des huit avec
l'idée si on prend ces six ont fait ou
reprendre des deux dames prend des deux
dames point f3 mais il a choisi une
autre solution girofle il a joué dames 7
permettant tour 17
c'est un petit peu surprenant à moins
qu'ils le voient la dame et fuite mais
maintenant on a une excellente tour en
17 sur la septième rangée et c'est très
très important d'arriver à mettre une
tour septième rangée et jean-luc oui
tout à fait mais alexei et quand même
obnubilé par cette case des quatre donc
quand il a joué dame set c'était tout
simplement pour des clous et ce cavalier
au cices est bon ils oublient
provisoirement le pion f3 mais s'il
installe un cavalier en d4 je pense que
qui sera assez satisfaits dans cette
position puisqu'il pourra le
éventuellement le soutenir par un pion
c5
donc ils oublient un petit peu la 7e
pendant un coût et la joie oui et en
plus en plus il pourra s'il avait
arriver d'ici l'été
vu la possibilité de jouer cavalier des
cats il aurait repris la colonne des
sans aucun problème défendu son pion c6
ça c'est clair
well dans cette position a joué il a
joué tour des deux des six donc joël qui
encore créer des menaces tactique donc
en activant ses pièces donc là
maintenant on échange d'une tour donc
pas retour ces sept on vous échanger ses
tours puisque après le cavalier peut
revenir donc tout reprend ses sept tours
prend ses sept tours de france et cette
dame prend des six plus tôt dawit on
prend cette dame prend des six excusez
moi donc et après damas prendrait six
les noirs ont une position correcte
puisqu'ils contrôlent la case des 4 mai
la tour en septième peut quand même leur
poser quelques petits soucis c'est un
très bon coup à jouer shirov dans cette
position tour c7 est vraiment est
vraiment très bien
on va laisser la parole à arnaud
hauchard qui va nous donner ses
impressions sur la phase de cette partie
oui allô oui je j'ai pensé à ce plan de
fou c'est ça qu'il faut prendre le temps
d'échanger des pho de cases noires et il
se trouve que là
la structure est fixé quand même pour
les blancs il ya peu de manoeuvre en
fait et lequel le cavalier noir est
quand même plus fort bien que le pion à
4 faible en fait il faut éviter la
finale pour l'une pour les noirs mais je
viens de jouer dame b 6 mais peut-être
que tours b 8 est très très dangereux
dans cette position hewitt tombé 8 a été
joué et où va la dame dans cette
position sur dame à 5
il se passe tout simplement tout reprend
17 et le pion à 3 est perdu et la taille
du pion b2 et fatale est tout à fait
jean-luc il semble que joel les gaffes
et avec le ku'damm eb66 et c'est
vraiment terrible
effectivement damas cinq ont fait tout
simplement tout reprend 17 tours prend
des sacs dame prend à 3 et le pion b2
est cloué à cause du roi en b1 aïe aïe
aïe incroyable une dame qui est rentré à
la maison comme ça en recettes et en
fuite qui peut ressurgir en a3 c'était
quand même
manoeuvre fantastique alors peut-être
l'idée maintenant c'est surtout reprend
tout reprendre d'un prend 1,3 il
resterait encore cavaliers prend à 4
pour défendre b2 mais vraiment la
position alors attention il ya une
ressource après dame prend à trois
peut-être que les blancs peuvent jouer
aussi tour des huit échecs et sur
cavaliers prend des huit d'apprendre des
8 mai et visant une qualité de moins
elle c'est fini voilà dame prend à trois
cavaliers des incas jouer joël mais ça
vraiment ça tourne mal pour pour le
numéro un français qui a gaffé jean-luc
en jouant dame b 6 1 il a sans doute
oublié cette possibilité bref trois
dames points 9-3 joël n'a plus que 3
minutes 25e contre 8 minutes 48 il
il vient de perdre un pion est donc
actuellement il souffre et voilà donc
shirov qui qui lance l'offensive c'est
très très dur là pour le joueur français
et là il doit trouver une case pour la
dame donc et la dame ne peut pas venir
et encore oui il perd le 4 c'est ça et
la dame ne peut plus défendre le pion
aux quatre c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable donc une gaffe terrible qui
vient de l'autre bout de l'échiquier
puisque la dame et fuite après le pion
aura trois c'est donc ce quiproquo échec
donc les grandes diagonales doivent être
doivent être contrôlés oui c'est
vraiment bon mais il faut dire que
shirov ne rate jamais ce type de
possibilités joël a dû jouer vite à
cause bien sûr du temps il n'a pas eu
sans doute la possibilité de vérifier
toutes les variantes et il a gaffé là il
doit perdre le pion aux quatre ce qui
est terrible il va faire dame prend 4
bien sûr sur échec voilà ce qui est bien
sûr dramatique dans la mesure où son roi
non seulement il a un déficit en
matériel mais son roi se retrouvent dans
les courants d'air et ça risque de très
mal tourner pour le roi blanc dans les
minutes qui vont suivre
oui donc c'est une finale technique
c'est à dire que dans cette position les
blancs donc son
désespéré mais il faut continuer de
toute façon pour le spectacle et parce
que on sait jamais au bon il faudrait
qu'ils récupèrent du temps parce qu'il
lui reste deux minutes 33 32 contre 8
minutes 05 pour alexei shirov donc voilà
à l'excès qui vient de jouer donc tour
c5
alexei qui est en train de chercher le
match probablement oui là ça ça va très
mal on peut peut-être joué tour des huit
dans cette position pour essayer de
détourner le cavalier qui défend la tour
en c5 et puis pourquoi pas créer on est
obligé de prendre des huit d'un procès
cinq peut-être ça permettrait de
soulager un petit peu la position mais
salah simplifie aussi il ya beaucoup de
pur - quand même pour pour les blancs
oui tout à fait surtout qu'après donc
tour des huit cavaliers prendra fin
d'année trois dames e3 donc encore à une
proposition des changes
joël est malin il essaie de te garder
ses pièces active au cas où pascal excès
il va probablement refusé
alexei dans cette position va essayer de
mater pour le spectacle mais c'est
peut-être la chance de joël justement
qu'il joue pour le spectacle et qui
n'oublie qu'il en perde sa lucidité
c'est tout ce qu'on pourrait souhaiter à
joël si alexis shirov pouvait fonds
phare au nez un petit peu dans cette
position oui mais c'est le rôle de
chacun de ses joueurs
le rôle de ces joueurs est de gagner
avec avec un esprit un esprit
spectaculaire avec le volonté de faire
des sacrifices donc là alexei anon
alexei qui décide tout simplement de
jouer le plus direct et qui se dirige
vers une finale très très dur donc eloi
oui alors effectivement la situation de
l'ol a l'air très délicate dans la
mesure où il est mal autant il a moins
de deux minutes maintenant alexei shirov
est quant à lui né à 7 minutes
donc ça va être très très difficile
cette finale et est probablement
perdante
puisqu'on a déjà d'options de moins le
pion h5 va tomber et d'autant plus c'est
d'autant plus difficile que les blancs
n'ont pas de pions passé alors que les
noirs en ont
on simplement curage qui va qui va
foncer tellement flèche donc ici
position très difficile pour jouer qui
est mal autant voilà alexei shirov
ramasse le pion et revient
tranquillement ça va être très très dur
pour notre numéro un français met enfin
à noter quand même que son adversaire
n'est pas le dernier des joueurs puisque
aux mélodies en dehors de monaco où il
avait gagné tous les matches qu'ils
avaient joué
oui mais c'est vraiment dommage quand
meme de d'avoir gaffe est dans une
position qui était très tendue où il
n'était pas absolument menacée de perdre
il aurait pu essayer de jouer solide
pour obtenir le nul et puis jouer sa
chance dans les matchs de départage
voilà la défaite donc de joël lautier
malheureusement la finale opposera
demain alexis shirov à boris spassky
l'ancien champion du monde
bravo aux deux joueurs pour faire une
magnifique c'est une victoire de alexei
shirov dans ce match on peut être à
l'excellent sam smart phone tablet os
que windows update et em no 3 4 6 6 1 6
0 6 2 je vais lui confirma peut-être le
ku'damm b si c'était une erreur oui
c'était pas très bons et parce que j'ai
oublié que le pion entre eux était en
prise tout simplement donc
après ça j'étais foutu mais avant ça
c'était pas c'est pas si clair je sais
pas si je suis vraiment moins bien bon
c'est sûr que j'ai pas beaucoup de temps
donc c'est important dans ce genre de
position parce que c'est très compliqué
mais bon je mets bien opposition quand
même
en tout cas on peut applaudir parce
qu'ils ont fourni un très bon match
donc demain à 10h30 on aura droit donc
un match entre joël lautier et arnaud
hauchard est suivi donc à 13h30 d'impôts
entre les deux matches et à 14h30 de la
finale entre alexei shirov et boris
spassky voilà vous dis à demain